[Music]
lindsay's with us in columbia south
carolina hi lindsay how are you
hey dave i'm doing great how are you
guys better than we deserve what's up in
your world
yeah so i just recently got engaged and
my fiance and i have been following your
baby steps for a few years now we are
debt free
um so now we are now planning and
budgeting for the wedding which we will
be able to cash flow
but yeah
but i
i am finding myself having a lot of
guilt um over
spending the money on the wedding
we are both anticipating we are going to
need new cars soon we're at the phase of
our life where we'd like to start saving
for a down payment um i don't want to
jit myself of the wedding um that i want
but i am having
shame about wanting to spend so much
money well i mean it it
wouldn't be shameful or guilt-inducing
unless it is
too much money and and the way we how do
we save too much money it's in relative
terms
to your situation okay if you make two
million dollars a year
and you want to spend 50 grand on a
wedding that's not too much
if you make 40 000 a year and you want
to spend 50 grand on a wedding you're
crazy so what is it you want to spend on
the wedding
uh i think it's going to be about 25
to 30 grand tops nice wedding
and what is your what is your income
uh household income is probably about 90
000. well there's not a household yet
but yeah okay yeah yeah all right but
yeah that would be uh the numbers we're
dealing with anyway so
well the average household
income in america right now is about 70
000 and the average wedding is about 25
000.
okay okay now so that that's the average
but we do want to keep in mind that
normal is broke so we don't necessarily
want to aim at average but the point of
that is you're not completely out of
control
but now you start to make value
judgments and go
every five thousand dollars i cut this
accelerates
the other goals
and so it's the trade-off that you're
going to make the rest of your life if i
spend money on a i don't have it for b
it's called opportunity cost
and that's what i'm struggling with like
i don't want to have the wedding
and then
what i want you to do is set a pla set a
number
stick to that number
and never struggle again
okay now you should uh i i do want some
of this
negative emotion to keep you from
overspending your budget
and so what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes
i would probably say
you know we're i just don't feel okay
about 25 i'm because you're not feeling
okay about it
by the way i'm kind of kind of keying
off of that
okay it wasn't like you're going this is
because let me just tell you the
difference in twenty thousand dollar
wedding twenty five thousand dollar
wedding no one that visits will know
that's a napkin arrangement
yeah
that's the chairs you chose for the
reception you know i mean oh my god so
and then when you start laying out the
actual wedding budget
you know so you put a big number on it
and then you say based on that i'm gonna
spend x on the
uh videos and pictures i'm gonna spend y
on the dress i'm gonna spend z
on the uh
reception i'm gonna you know and every
one of the l the band the dj the the
preacher
the whatever and you just line item this
out like it's a project because i'm
sorry darling but it is
and then you stick to that you say okay
i've got this much budgeted for catering
and they go well you can't get the sushi
if you do that well then we won't be
having sushi darling so this
no is a possible answer to some of these
questions
and so um but the the thing that will
give you great peace and no guilt is if
you'll set a number detail it out and
then stick to it you'll never think
about it again but if it's constantly
floating around and you feel like then i
can buy happiness or i can buy joy for
three thousand dollars more
you're not going to find it there it's
not there and it is a it's a wonderful
thing to have big we have big parties
we're
ramsey's man we like to party all of our
weddings were huge we love big weddings
and everybody dancing and and good food
and man it's a fun time and it is one
day and it's gone
it is it does evaporate but so is travel
or so there's other things we spend
money on so right but
there is no quote you do know there is
no correlation between the size of the
wedding budget and the success of the
marriage though right
yes
if anything there might be a negative
correlation
yeah yeah for sure well i'm just glad
we're not going into debt for it but i
do have that guilt
you know
you know what i'm saying i'm not glad i
have i chose yeah not to go into debt
for it
you're like being a grown grown-up and
stuff here
yeah is is the person you're about to
marry are they
guilt-tripping you
are saying man if we weren't doing a
wedding like this like where's this
guilt coming from
me um i guess because we we have worked
so hard the last few years to pay off
our debt and now we're in a finally in a
really good financial spot are you kind
of a taiwan you have trouble enjoying
money
yes um and and i just i'm worried that
after the wedding our cars are going to
go and we're going to need they are they
are 100 100 chance
and you know what i'm gonna honeymoon
one of them's gonna fry in 15 years
it'll be a funny footnote to a great
wedding
yeah let this be a great experience for
you
to
you worked so hard so that
you could honor this i like that this
cool ceremony right that's why you're
gonna work so hard after this wedding to
you're gonna get new cars so that you
don't end up on the side of the road
you're going to work really hard to pay
off your house so that you can give
recklessly to people in your community
you're going to do these things so that
right and you all have worked really
hard to get right here i would challenge
you to dial it down to 20. absolutely
18.5 come up with a number yeah and then
just then just lock it in
and go based on that i've got to do the
dress this way
based on that i've got to do the
catering this way based on that i got to
have friends go pick some uh daisies out
of the farmer's field because we don't
have money for a florist based on that i
don't know what it is but i mean i've
had folks on this team in the last two
years three years four years
many many many of them have had some
incredible weddings for under 10 grand
yeah
but it
it involved friends pitching in
mom's cooking stuff for the rest i mean
involved all kinds of different things
you can do
you don't have to do that you're not
doing anything morally wrong or
financially wrong if you just say the
budget's 20 and we're going to hire it
all out that's okay but my point is is
that you can have a really nice wedding
for 20k and one thing that helps me in
these moments of spend and feel guilty
is
if you you had this 25 000 budget and
you decided to roll it down to 18.5 make
sure you take that gap money and you
apply it to one of these things on the
back end like i'm going to use this for
a car i'm going to use this for those
things so you'll feel like you're
getting ahead and you're getting this
great wedding but
i'm like you dave we've
i've seen some pretty inventive and
creative weddings over the last couple
of years because of covid and they're
awesome and they're all still married
and they're not a hundred thousand
dollars in the hole no no
let me no you don't borrow for a wedding
no no
but she's not doing that she's not doing
that she's
what a great young lady very incredible